- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is stop believing in luck.
Over to you, Oprah Winfrey.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- Nothing about my life is lucky, nothing.
A lot of grace, a lot of blessings,
a lot of divine order, but
I don't believe in luck.
For me luck is preparation
meeting the moment of opportunity.
There is no luck without
you being prepared
to handle that moment of opportunity,
and so what I would say for myself
is that because of my hand in a hand
and a force greater than my own,
I have been prepared in ways
that I didn't even know
I was being prepared for,
and the truth is, for
me and for every person,
every single thing that has
ever happened in your life
is preparing you for the
moment that is to come.
- So I'm not a huge
believer in luck either.
You know, was it lucky
that I was born in Canada?
Yes.
Was it lucky that I have amazing parents?
Was it lucky that I
didn't get hit by a bus
on the way to the studio
today to film for you guys?
Yes.
Was it lucky for me in entrepreneurship?
Did it help in my business career?
Maybe.
What I love doing is looking at success.
I love modeling success,
and I look at who's had the most success,
who are the people who
built the big companies,
and it's almost never the people
who are the children of
really wealthy people.
It's almost never the people
who have the most luck
in the world, who had everything
kind of handed to them.
They had the most opportunity
to create amazing things.
They had connections and they
had money and they had family
and they had relationships
and they had education,
all the things that people
think are really important.
Look at the top people who
built the most amazing companies
and look at their backgrounds.
Most of them started off with nothing.
Most of them don't credit education,
a formal education at
least as being a thing
that really helped them, if
they even had formal education.
Most of them didn't have
great family connections.
A lot of them are immigrants
who came to the country with zero.
The ones who were born here
didn't have a lot of money either.
Despite them being unlucky,
these are the guys who made it,
and so I think a lot of people blame luck
for them not having success.
You look at someone
who's had massive success
and say, "Well, they were
just lucky," and you know why?
'Cause it makes you feel
good about yourself.
'Cause as long as you can
believe that it's luck
that is causing these
people to be successful,
it's luck that he got that loan
or luck that she built
that business or luck,
as long as you believe it's luck,
then you don't have to take
any personal responsibility.
You're just not lucky.
That's not your fault.
It's not your fault you're not lucky.
Those guys are lucky, you're not lucky.
You're the same as them,
you worked just as hard,
you have the greatest
ideas just like them.
The only difference is luck.
And if that's what you believe,
then you're going to stay
exactly where you are,
and so that's the difference.
Taking personal accountability and saying,
"I am where I am because of me."
Growing up, you know, you're
living with your parents,
you take on their values, you
do what they ask you to do
to some extent, but at
some point you decide,
"I'm an adult, I'm
going to change my life.
"I'm going to set the course
for what I'm going to do."
It's nobody else's fault anymore.
You know, if you're not being fed
when you're three years
old, that's not your fault.
But if you're not being fed
when you're 25 years old,
30 years old, 40 years
old, that's your fault.
You got to get out and
start doing the work,
and so I think a lot of
people just blame bad luck
as an excuse for not doing the work.
I'm also a big believer in you have to,
you play the cards that you're dealt.
Like a good poker player
can win with any hand,
so you just got to develop the skills,
and a terrible poker player
can lose with two aces,
and so just figuring out,
"This is what I've been dealt,"
so what?
Are you going to spend the entire
rest of your life complaining
that you weren't born in the right country
or have the right parents
or have the right education
or whatever excuses?
You're just going to throw it in?
That's your entire life now?
This is what you were dealt
and so I'm going to spend the
rest of my life complaining?
You do what you can with what you have.
That's one of my favorite quotes
from Steve Wozniak, co-founder of Apple.
They started with nothing.
He sold his calculator to
raise money and to start Apple,
and he loves saying that too many people
focus on what they don't have,
or the successful people think about
what you should be doing with
what you already do have.
You have a lot.
You have brains, you have
the ability to hustle,
you've got heart, you've got
ideas, you've got passion.
You could turn that crazy
idea that's inside your head
into reality, and you don't need luck,
and you don't need most of the things
that people think you need.
You just got to do the work every day
and accept the responsibility that you are
in your life where you
are only because of you.
Once you take that responsibility
and accountability, then you also realize
that you have the ability to change it.
When you make that commitment,
amazing things start to happen.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what are your thoughts on luck?
Do you believe in it or not?
Does it help you in your business?
Do you need it?
Is it a requirement for success?
Let me know what you think.
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Bonnie Ottaviani.
Bonnie, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you guys tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- You know, people like Mozart
and Beckham and the great athletes,
humanitarians, entrepreneurs,
chess champions,
were less about genetics
and natural talent
and what makes icons in
whatever field you choose.
It's not your talent.
It's things like the
amount that you practice,
your ability to stay with your practice
for the 10,000 hours, your social circle.
I mean, what made the great
Brazilian footballers great
was not that they have some natural thing
by living in Brazil.
It's every little kid from pretty much
the moment he's three or
four years old, right,
sees the heroes and it's
the ticket out of poverty,
and so all they do is touch the football
every single day and night,
and by the time they're 11 years old,
they've touched the
football millions of times
and they are therefore untouchable
compared to anyone else around the world,
and all I'm saying is,
genius is not something you're born with.
Genius is something that you apply.
You don't get lucky, you make lucky.
Success is not something
that is, you know,
divinely bestowed on you.
Success, whether it's
prosperity or whatever it is,
is something that you
earn by grit, hard work,
finding the right people,
doing the learning, et cetera.
- Nothing in life is free.
Nothing happens overnight.
It all takes tons and tons of work
and tons and tons of talent
and tons of tons of serendipity,
but my friends, luck, serendipity,
there's a forced culture within that.
You know, you don't just
sit in your room hoping
and then something lucky happens.
Nobody just knocks on your
house's door and says,
"Congratulations, you've
been awarded this."
Luck comes from being in the right spot.
I've been really lucky
because I bleed out of my eyes
every day of my life and work my face off.
You get really lucky when you
have that 11:30 PM meeting
and one of the lucky thing happen.
Pretty cool, since all you were sleeping.
I was pretty lucky.
Weird that I scheduled that meeting
'cause I did a ton of things for 30 years
that allowed me to even have
that meeting in the first place
that gave me the leverage to
have that lucky thing happen.
There's no overnight successes, period.
They don't exist.
Show me, leave a comment
on YouTube, leave the name,
explain to me, tell me, show me,
let me know, show me
the overnight success,
because I'll show you you
justifying in your brain
something that is just not true, period.
- The universe of passion
is open to everybody.
But many people don't know.
They believe passion should
come down from the sky.
No, you go to find your passion.
Passion will not come to you.
It is like luck, luck cannot come to you.
You can buy as many Lotto things,
you can make bets on Barcelona and Madrid.
Luck will never come to you.
But you go to luck,
that's much more secure.
You go and go to take luck.
If you stay and luck comes
down to you, forget it.
You will die and no luck will ever come.
Luck is a process where you
move to luck and you take luck
and you say, "Come on
luck, I keep you now,"
and you take another
one tomorrow and so on.